it's now more than 72 hours since russia
began its land sea and air invasion of
ukraine russian forces have already made
their way into the capital kiev fighting
and destroying cities bordering it
here's the latest information residents
are waking up to these images of their
city after another night of loud
explosions and firing russian troops
have been seen inside moletopol in the
south east it witnessed heavy fighting
on friday the ukrainian military command
says cruise missiles are being launched
from the black sea
on friday russian forces captured an
island there after ukrainians refused to
surrender
ukraine's presidential office says more
than 3
500 russian service personnel have been
ki have been killed and almost 200 were
captured this has not been verified
in another video message the ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky has vowed to
continue fighting
good morning ukrainians there has been a
lot of fake information online saying
that i'm calling on our army to lay down
arms and to evacuate
listen i am here we will not lay down
any weapons we will defend our state
because our weapon is our truth and the
truth is that this is our land our
country and our children and we will
defend all of that that's all i wanted
to tell you glory to ukraine
okay we will go to mike hanna in
washington in a moment first let's go
live to andrew simmons who's in the
capital there kiev for us so andrew
what's your reading of what we've been
hearing from mr zielenski overnight
well zielinski has never said he will
contemplate surrender he did ask for
talks with vladimir putin and he was
given an impossible
situation there uh with a with a
uh only an offer to have talks uh about
peace if he was to surrender and those
talks would have to be uh with victor
lukashanka in minsk the capital of
belarus
so
this is now
it would appear he thinks things are in
their final stages but he's reliant on
the strength of will of his forces to
take on the russians because the
situation is getting harder and harder
by the hour um the position now is
something of a lull
but no the
the
feeling is that the final battle for
kiev is beginning
it may be beginning andrew but is there
a sense that
the russian forces haven't achieved what
they wanted to achieve by this the
beginning of day three
i think it there's uh the there is an
overwhelming force here uh but the
russians have been held back it would
seem uh with fierce more fierce
resistance than they had contemplated
they had expected they've taken heavier
losses
undoubtedly the latest reports we have
is that two illusion
76
troop carriers transport carriers
for the russian air force have been shot
down 185 kilometers from the capital the
other about 25 kilometers said to have
been shot down near an airfield now
these reports haven't been verified yet
but the wire agencies are quoting
american sources as confirming a figure
of two for those those transport planes
they carry more than 100 paratroopers
plus equipment
and we do know that other planes have
got through and and paratroopers have
been deployed
in areas near the capital special forces
also
and the armored columns are coming from
all directions the one that was
advancing from the west
was taken on and repelled by armour from
the ukrainians and also missiles that
was actually at
a place called um
this was a metro station uh in the
suburbs but we're talking now really of
the fighting going on in a seven
kilometer radius of where i'm standing
it is it is uh here that the public
buildings uh are standing with undamaged
at this stage there's an eerie stillness
but then when the fighting starts it's
just
a cacophony
of wailing air raid sirens and crunches
and smashes and and all the things you'd
expect it's been a pretty horrendous 24
hours and very few people have slept
overnight and when it turns quiet andrew
in the morning as it seems to do
on a regular basis now this is day three
as as we were discussing is that part of
the plan is that part of the tactic or
is it just that it's easier for the
russians to try and do what they're
trying to do
under cover of darkness
i'm not a military analyst but i would i
would certainly point to that last uh
remark you made uh cover of darkness is
always uh an asset to uh an invading
force
and it's harder to defend so yes this
this has been happening uh overnight was
probably the biggest push on the capital
so far but of course intense fighting
all over this country with uh the uh the
russian navy
engaging the ukrainian navy as well uh
one uh battleship from the ukrainian
navy has been hit that's another report
that hasn't been confirmed yet but it's
a pretty hazardous situation for
everyone particularly the civilians
obviously any glimpse of diplomacy any
glimpse of anyone
talking to anyone else
it would appear not um the u.n security
council which you'll be hearing about
from mike i'm sure later but is is is
yet another stamp of of disaster on any
prospect for negotiations uh
we had zielinski trying to engage
calling those extraordinary calls for um
europeans to lobby their their
governments to do more uh to actually
try to get the russia uh
brought to heal
by stronger sanctions
but that is not going to happen it would
seem although if the ukrainians can hold
on the issue is how long can they hold
on could there be more diplomatic
measures if more pressure was put on
russia
then that is the the real issue right
now is how long can the ukrainian forces
keep defending the capital and the other
major cities uh that you know one has to
look at those as well yes right now
there is a priority in military terms in
taking the capital uh and uh zelenske
zalinski says that he is the main target
along with the leadership and he's even
said that his family
is is the main target as well so this is
um a position now where
the the clock is ticking in every way
militarily in terms of how long can
people keep the defenses going and how
long could diplomacy that the chances of
diplomacy last
i'd say very very limited indeed and for
the people the anger amongst the people
is extraordinary the resolve of the
fighters
is absolutely extraordinary as well
because zelensky said one more thing it
was a very short address and it was
right outside the presidential offices
we've identified those without any
shadow of doubt and he was saying that
that he
respected the bravery of his fighters he
quoted uh from
a military officer who had reported back
on um one of the soldiers going on to a
bridge a main bridge on one of the
access routes into the capital and
having to defend it because of what was
going on all around him he went to
detonate
the bridge to explode it and not lost
his life in the process it was an act of
ultimate courage
andrew thank you very much andrew
simmons there joining us live from kiev
with the very latest about what's going
on in and around the ukrainian capital
live now as andrew was saying there to
mike hannah our correspondent in
washington so mike as far as mr
zielinski's relationship with the us is
concerned it's a case of thanks but no
thanks i don't want you to evacuate me
well it would appear to be so there have
been various reports that the us has
offered to help evacuate the ukrainian
president but at this stage uh certainly
appears to be uh the very opposite in
terms of what he would want
administration official has confirmed
that the have been discussions with
president zelinski about where he would
be safest to ensure the continuity of
the ukrainian government and on thursday
the press secretary at the white house
was asked directly whether the u.s was
going to offer assistance and
she said that there have been
discussions about the various ways in
which the u.s can assist the ukrainian
president
but then would not give any further
details because she said of security
concerns uh but as we heard there from
andrew um president zielinski is
insistent that he's not going anywhere
with or without anybody's help and
what's the nature of this aid package
that the u.s has just announced as well
well this is a direct instruction from
president biden to the secretary of
state to
release
350 million dollars worth of military
assistance now a lot of this is still
for training purposes as much of the
money in the last year some 650 million
dollars has been assigned to however
specifically it's also stated that there
is some contents of military equipment
within this package what it is not quite
clear uh it's speculation is that it
involves items like javelin missiles um
but what we are hearing as well is that
this is a presidential instruction and
it's done under a presidential
regulation which allows the president to
apportion such money or instruct the
apportionment of such money without uh
consulting congress now on a separate
issue congress in the coming week is
continuing to debate a massive 650
billion dollar uh budget for
humanitarian relief in ukraine so it's
happening on all sorts of levels but the
350 million that president biden has
instructed be released
that is in terms of an ongoing program
of assistance to ukraine uh particularly
with regard to training but there again
you've got the issue logistically given
the situation in ukraine very difficult
to see how any aid can get across the
borders at this particular time mike
understood thanks so much mike hannah
there joining us from washington